there are people we are friends with for
one major but often maligned or
overlooked reason because we were
friends with them some time ago at one
stage it might be decades ago now we had
a lot in common
we were both good at maths but bad at
French at school and had a shared liking
for table tennis or we had adjacent
rooms at college and used to help each
other with assignments and commiserate
in the bar about failed dates or
maddening parents or maybe we were
interns in the same big firm with the
same as we thought at the time bizarre
and intemperate boss but life has taken
us on radically different courses now
they've got three young children they
moved to the Orkneys where they're
managing a fish farm or they've gone
into politics and have become a junior
minister or they're working as a ski
teacher in the Rocky Mountains the daily
realities of our lives may be miles
apart we may know little of their world
and they of ours if we were introduced
today we think each other pleasant
enough but would never get close yet it
can be hugely helpful and very
redemptive to catch up with these people
with a one-on-one dinner a walk in the
woods or the occasional email these
Friends function as conduits to earlier
versions of ourselves that are
inaccessible day to day but that contain
hugely important insights in the company
of the old friend we take stock of the
journey we have traveled we get to see
how we've evolved what was once painful
what mattered or what we've wholly
forgotten we deeply enjoyed the old
friend is a guardian of memories on
which we might otherwise have a damaging
ly tenuous hold we need old friends
because of a crucial complexity in human
nature we pass through stages of
development and as we do so we discard
previous concerns and may develop a lack
of empathy around past perspectives at
14 we knew a lot about resenting our
parents twenty years later the whole
idea sounds absurd and ungrateful yet
the old friend reconnects us with a
particular atmosphere
and like a novelist makes us at home
with a character ourselves who might
otherwise have seemed impossibly alien
to us at 22 we found single life
extremely painful we hung out a lot with
a particular friend and shared a litany
of wistful alienated thoughts at 45 with
a young family around us we may find
ourselves increasingly curious about
being single again and fantasize about
the joys of casual hookups the old
friend has crucial news to impart
we experience life from a succession of
very different vantage points over the
decades but we tend understandably to be
preoccupied only with a present Vista
forgetting the particular incomplete but
still crucial wisdom contained in
earlier phases every age possesses a
superior kind of knowledge in some area
or other which it then usually forgets
to hand on to succeeding selves
remembering what it was like not to be
who we are now is vital to our growth
and integrity the best professors remain
friends with their past they remember
what it was like not to know about their
special topic and so don't talk her for
the heads of their students the best
bosses are in touch with their own
experience of starting out as a lowly
employee the best politicians clearly
recall periods in their lives when they
held very different views to the ones
they've now formulated which allows them
to persuade and empathize with hostile
constituencies good parents keep
emotionally in touch with the feelings
of injustice and sensitivity they had in
early childhood kindly wealthy people
remember what it was like not to dare to
walk into a fancy food shop for fear of
being patronized and we are always
better long-term lovers if we have an
avenue of loyalty back to who we were
when we first met our beloved and Wirt
an Apogee of gratitude and modesty old
friends are key activators of
fascinating and valuable parts of the
self that we need but are always at risk
of forgetting we need in the blinkered
present we publish new thought-provoking
films every week be sure to subscribe to
our Channel and take a look at more of
what we have to offer at the link on
your screen now
you